[Musik]
nein baracke geht es nicht nur ums
trinken es geht ums große ganze
mindestens wacker ist der türkische
nationalteam gefahr mit serkan erdal und
murat sitzen wir in ihrem stammlokal
noch bis zum wochenende dürfen
restaurants in der türkei öffnen dann
erst geld neue corona auflagen serkan
und seine freunde diskutieren das
schicksal des racks und damit natürlich
der ganzen türkischen nation
es gibt hier eine 500 bis 600 jahre alte
recke kultur raacke wird mit freunden an
einem langen tisch getrunken
mit einigen vorspeisen und mit vielen
gesprächen das destillat dass die
türkische seele wärmt ist im laufe der
jahre immer teurer geworden für unsere
drei raacke kenner ist es ein versuch
der streng islamischen regierung von
präsident erdogan dem volk den alkohol
abzugewöhnen und damit auch noch geld zu
verdienen
man hat in letzter zeit tatsächlich
versucht uns den rat zu verleihen
man hat die steuern stark angehoben das
hat den alkoholkonsum erschwert ich sage
nur versucht bloß nicht uns unseren raki
ganz wegzunehmen
es gibt kaum ein land das so hohe
alkoholsteuer hat wie die türkei wenn
man zwischen den zeilen liest ist das
eine form der kulturellen und
moralischen unterdrücken
auf der anderen seite stützen die die
trotz der hohen preise weiter trinken
die türkische wirtschaft ganz erheblich
und die kann jede hilfe gebrauchen die
korona pandemie trifft wirtschaft und
verbraucher auch die türkei kämpft gegen
steigende infektionszahlen wie viele
tatsächlich positiv getestet werden weiß
niemand seit september meldet die
regierung nur die zahl der erkrankten
doch die lage ist offenbar ernst denn am
kommenden wochenende gilt eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre
von acht uhr abends bis 10 uhr morgens
da könnte der alkoholverbrauch wieder
steigen
diese zusatzeinnahmen aber wandern fast
alle in die staatskasse in ankara und
nicht in die kasse von kds kleinem laden
kostete eine 0,7 liter flasche raki bei
amtsantritt von erdogans
regierungspartei umgerechnet noch rund
einen euro sind es heute rund 20 80
prozent davon gehen an den staat würde
ich nicht auch noch lebensmittel
verkaufen mein kader wäre ich schon
längst pleite
weil die steuern auf alkohol so hoch
sind sind unsere verkaufszahlen zurück
gegangen ein mensch der sich gerade so
mit dem mindestlohn über wasser hält
kann sich das nicht mehr leisten
stattdessen geht er und kaufte sich
gepanschten alkohol für einen euro 5
sein freund joseph sagt kadir aber aus
diesem grund gerade erst seine schwester
verloren
josef nimmt uns mit in sein kleines
schnellrestaurant der tod seiner
schwester yelda ging sogar durch die
abendnachrichten yelda war nur eine von
vielen
allein in den vergangenen sechs wochen
starben laut türkischen innenministerium
67 menschen an einer vergiftung mit
methylalkohol
[Musik]
meine schwester ist am 9 oktober ins
krankenhaus gekommen
17 tage lang lag sie auf der
intensivstation
kurz nachdem man sie von der
intensivstation entlassen hatte ist sie
noch in derselben nacht um 4 uhr
verstorben
gepanschter alkohol sei ein fluch klagt
mutter turin und schuld daran seien die
hohen alkoholsteuern der regierung
wenn jemand sein beileid ausspricht
möchte ich am liebsten sterben
ich habe meine wunderschöne tochter
begraben müssen warum tut keiner was
keiner zeit irgendwas warum
wie so viele in der türkei hatte sich
auch turins tochter ihren racky zu hause
selbst zusammengemischt
im internet fand sie die anleitung und
adressen bei denen sie die zutaten
bestellen konnte doch sie bekam eine
falsche eine tödliche lieferung gelder
wurde nur 47 jahre alt sie bezahlte 200
lehrer für itil alkohol
aber sie bekam methylalkohol im wert von
20 lehrer
das ist ein unglaublicher unterschied
diese mörder verdienen an ihrem tod die
stecken sich 180 liter in die tasche
groß razzia in einer illegalen alkohol
fabrik längst beherrschen mafiabanden
das milliardengeschäft mit gefälschtem
racke rum whisky und wodka gerade jetzt
in zeiten der korona pandemie steigt der
private alkoholkonsum und wegen der
hohen steuern gehen immer mehr menschen
im internet auf die suche nach
alternativen und billigen angeboten
würde der präsident die steuern und
damit den alkoholfreies senken gäbe es
wohl weniger tote niemand kann sie gern
seinen alkohol zu hause meint serkan
einer unserer raacke kenner doch dass
die regierung auf diese einnahmen
verzichten wird glaubt er nicht denn
große proteste brauche sie in einem
islamischen land wie der türkei nicht zu
fürchten
man beschwert sich untereinander darüber
aber bisher ist niemand deswegen auf die
straße gegangen
in der türkei ist es nicht einfach wegen
hoher alkohol preise straßenproteste zu
organisieren
das hat vor allem etwas mit dem islam
mit den hiesigen werten und mit den
moralvorstellungen zu tun
protestiert wird nur am stammtisch
tagsüber beim tee und abends beim racky
dort wälzen sie die probleme der
türkischen nation und fragen sich wohin
das alles noch führen
[Musik]